congrats on your work in the movie
oh thanks a lot i love that guy behind
this one
yeah yeah it's like a statue i don't
actually know what the right terminology
is
uh but i'll give credit it's it's really
cool it's strong
it's strong yeah i did an interview with
benedict recently and he got
uh it was a very good exchange oh nice
benedict's a lovely guy super nice uh
he's kind of talented but enough about
him let's jump into talking
to you um i love learning about the
behind the scenes of the making
of movies especially marvel movies is
there anything that you think might
surprise people to learn about the
making of black widow
well i i mean i i
i don't know if it would surprise people
to know
that that scarlett and florence actually
kind of had a sisterly relationship
offset as well like it was so playful
and fun
and you know they would just mess around
off camera i'm not surprised that that
charisma and connection between them
kind of transferred onto the screen as
well
uh one of the things about black widow
is that you have been
you obviously have to you have to talk
about the movie but you are you have to
talk without saying anything what has it
been like for you
uh trying to balance that oh listen
nobody people in my family no one asked
me any questions no one's injured you
know like
it's not hard and then what people on
the internet you know whatever you know
it's not it's not a hard thing for me
it's it's it's
exciting to see how much fans are
committed to this storyline and to
to the show and to wanting to know what
what's happening but in terms of hard
i've got no pressure on me it's fine
that's uh uh oh not what i expected but
one of the things i really dig about
this movie is that there's very serious
parts but there's also some really
really funny parts in it
it manages some really so can you sort
of talk about how the film
has both it's really serious and there's
also some pretty funny parts
yeah they they really gave us space to
play i was actually funny enough
shooting a comedy at the same time i was
shooting my show max which is on
hulu and when i'm playing this really
comic character and i think that bled in
a little bit to my character on on black
widow
because you know whenever there was the
opportunity there to crack a little joke
then
go for it and and scarlett is so fun and
funny got great sense of humor
you know we we played around a lot i
think uh in the shooting of this
show i read and i could be wrong but i
read you might be playing barack obama
uh in an upcoming uh television thing is
that true
yeah it's true i'm in atlanta now oh are
you filming it right now
yeah yeah yeah so i i definitely want to
know what
the hell is it like getting ready to
play
someone like that uh because i would
imagine it's daunting
yes there's a crushing pressure uh
i was just saying to someone that i i'm
they're the
showrunner of handmaid's tales sent me
an email saying you know talking about
various things at the end he was like
don't destroy his legacy and i was like
oh yeah thanks man no
pressure on me then um but you know at
the end of the day
i guess it i i'm more i've got this
great director i've got this great
script and i'm opposite by other davis
and the thing about working with
amazing actors is it just makes you
better so
you know i'm putting all my hopes on
them to be honest
like viola is kind of good um she's
talented
listen i already got to stop i'm just
going to say congrats on your work in
black widow
and i wish you nothing but the best
looking forward to seeing the barack
thing
thank you